sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales cuando la
guerra en ucrania está a punto de entrar
en su tercer mes rusia confirmó el
inicio de una nueva fase del conflicto
ahora enfocado en la liberación de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas populares de
danny ski lugansk que son reconocidas
por el kremlin
los ataques ahora se concentran y se
intensifican en el este del país y una
de las ciudades más golpeadas por esta
nueva estrategia militar es jarquín la
segunda más grande de ucrania donde las
autoridades siguen denunciando la muerte
de civiles como consecuencia de los
bombardeos desde el 24 de febrero los
cuerpos de bomberos y los médicos de
esta urbe trabajan día y noche sin parar
tras los constantes ataques ahora han
tenido que arriesgar sus vidas y
adaptarse a las nuevas condiciones de
trabajo este es un reportaje de cariño
restaurante juego milonga
a vida
me puse mi chaleco antibalas
para los conductores de ambulancias de
jarquín se ha convertido en una rutina
salir bajo las bombas rusas para atender
a los heridos
está claro que es peligroso trabajar en
primera línea pero si no somos nosotros
quién lo hará
van dirección salpica un distrito en el
norte de jarquín bombardeado noche y día
por la artillería de vladimir putin
company
los habitantes están conmocionados
varios misiles acaban de impactar en la
zona
no llores no llores
uno de ellos destruyó este edificio
residencial todas las ventanas fueron
destrozadas por la explosión y la
policía teme un segundo asalto
despejen despejen despejen
al otro lado de la calle un centro
comercial fue golpeado cuarteles
escuelas u hospitales
la artillería rusa no se anda con
pequeñeces desde el 24 de febrero el
cuerpo de bomberos dejar kif trabaja día
y noche
doctor ni lo peor es que a menudo
bombardean el mismo lugar varias veces
hemos tenido víctimas entre nuestras
filas
xstrata y protegidos
este supermercado filial local del grupo
francés auchan ha sido parcialmente
dominado por el fuego
para evacuar a las víctimas se
necesitarán varias ambulancias no pasa
nada somos ucranianos
en este los residentes locales
resultaron heridos por fragmentos de
vidrio
rusos es realmente
criminales de guerra
la señora mayor sigue en estado de shock
cuando llega a la sala de urgencias
el resultado del ataque un muerto 14
heridos
de vuelta al lugar del atentado donde
los residentes están limpiando siguen
conmocionados pero estoicos
eso no me importa svitlana profesora de
ucraniano jubilada nos invita a ver los
daños
el misil explotó en el hueco de la
escalera pero la onda expansiva no se
detuvo ahí
de hecho eso era todo lo que tenía
futuro
y este ha sobrevivido estoy tan feliz
los platos se cayeron están todos rotos
esto era muy bonito youtube
y al anochecer se reanudan los
bombardeos en el barrio
dirigido intencionalmente ataques contra
edificios dedicados a la religión las
artes o la educación es considerado como
un crimen de guerra según naciones
unidas
sólo en jarquín más de medio centenar de
centros educativos han sido destruidos
desde que comenzó la invasión rusa a
pesar de los ataques sistemáticos contra
las aulas profesores y estudiantes han
regresado a las clases online el
siguiente es un reportaje de etel bonet
y diego ibarra
natalia checa nova es profesora de
primaria y madre de una niña de 11 años
pese a la guerra y la destrucción de su
escuela ha vuelto a dar clases online
para intentar recuperar la normalidad
nos daña destruimos butler siento muy
feliz de volver a dar clase de hablar
con mis alumnos que los echaba tanto de
menos volver a ver sus sonrisas es muy
importante que sigan estudiando que no
se interrumpa en las clases
gracias la vuelta a las clases online su
hija verónica no se siente tan sola
estar en contacto con los compañeros de
clase hacer los deberes le ayudan a
lidiar con el miedo de los bombardeos
diarios
no puedo salir a jugar porque es
peligroso siempre están sonando las
sirenas de alarma y tenemos que
refugiarnos ahora he vuelto a ver mis
amigos y hablamos por su manita extraña
el 26 de marzo en la escuela donde
enseñaba natalia fue atacada por un
misil ruso de las 48 aulas que había en
este colegio sólo dos se han salvado a
la destrucción alina ha venido a ver
cómo ha quedado su escuela bajo las
montañas de escombros por las que camina
y hacen ahora sus recuerdos escolares
me pone muy triste pensar que no voy a
poder volver a esta escuela a mi clase y
estar con mis compañeros el último
recuerdo que tengo es que estábamos
haciendo unos pasteles en la clase de
cocina me da tanta pena brawn que get
schooled también es la los ataques a las
escuelas son considerados crímenes de
guerra y esta escuela es un testigo de
una víctima de esta guerra institutos
centros educativos guarderías están
siendo atacados todos los días aquí en
kharkiv rompiendo el futuro de una
generación al menos 190 mil tropas rusas
se han desplegado en ucrania desde el
inicio de la guerra pero poco se sabe de
los soldados que han sido enviados a
combatir muchos inexpertos y que
proceden de zonas marginadas del país
quienes son realmente los soldados de
rusos en el terreno lo vemos en el
siguiente informe
el desfile anual del día de la victoria
en rusia que se celebra en mayo es una
demostración de fuerza y de disciplina
pero desde el principio de la invasión a
ucrania empezaron a aparecer grietas
mostrando otra imagen del ejército ruso
la de la desorganización y los errores
de los soldados inexpertos cameros el
ejército ruso está formado por oficiales
y soldados no lograron crear un cuerpo
de oficiales subalternos que es un
cuerpo intermedio que tenemos en los
ejércitos occidentales cuando un
ejército carece de liderazgo los
soldados son abandonados a su suerte que
no hay manera de contenerlos y comandar
los de cerca para evitar errores y
atrocidades de voldemort es decir
section para suplir la falta de
liderazgo sobre el terreno algunos
generales rusos fueron llamados para ir
al frente un hecho extraño
otra cosa que la invasión ucraniana ha
puesto en el punto de mira es el origen
socioeconómico de los que se alistan en
el ejército ruso entre los soldados
rusos que han muerto en ucrania muchos
de ellos jóvenes e inexpertos ninguno es
de moscú
la gran mayoría procede de las regiones
más pobres donde alistarse en el
ejército es una oportunidad para
ascender en la escala social en
daguestán una de las regiones más pobres
el desempleo ronda el 15% tres veces más
que en el resto del país el salario
medio es de unos trescientos cincuenta
euros es decir unos cien euros menos de
lo que gana un soldado y
hay mucha gente que intenta alistarse
muchos jóvenes para los que el ejército
es la única salida en un entorno
económico muy cerrado todos estos
jóvenes son vistos como carne de cañón
el hecho de que mueran su salud su vida
el estado en el que volverán a casa del
ejército es la menor de las
preocupaciones del ejército
para compensar la inexperiencia de las
tropas el ejército ruso ha reclutado
mercenarios que han acumulado
experiencia luchando en guerras ajenas
el zoológico de nicolaides en más grande
y el más antiguo de europa con más de
120 años de existencia desde que empezó
la invasión rusa este lugar ha estado en
medio del fuego cruzado poniendo en
peligro la vida de los animales y de sus
cuidadores el siguiente es un reportaje
de etel bonet y diego ibarra sánchez
vladimir tops y lleva 40 años al cargo
del zoo más antiguo de europa pero desde
el pasado 27 de febrero su zoológico ha
quedado atrapado en medio de la guerra
de ucrania más de 3000 personas
visitaban al año este zoo que ahora está
vacío los animales están estresados por
el sonido de las sirenas y explosiones
que cerramos a los tigres por las noches
por si cae otro misil si se abrirá la
jaula se podrían escapar vladimir nos
muestra dónde cayó el misil y ahora se
exhiben como piezas de museo junto con
animales disecados
has oído en las explosiones pueden ser
los nuestros o los rusos en cualquier
momento puede caer otro misil tenemos
mucha suerte de estar vivos pese al
peligro de que el zoológico vuelva a ser
atacado vladimir y su equipo no han
dejado de venir ni un solo día para
cuidar a los más de 4.000 animales que
sienten como su propia familia porque
trabajo con animales desde hace 20 años
es mi segunda casa en cualquier
situación da igual lo que pase estoy
aquí para cuidarlos y protegerlos nos
necesitan sus chivos o cruz
este zoológico de 120 años ha vivido y
sobrevivido la segunda guerra mundial e
incluso ha sido refugio seguro para las
tropas soviéticas cuando los nazis
invadieron un cráneo hoy está bajo las
bombas diarias de las tropas rusas que
se encuentran a tan solo 30 kilómetros
de la ciudad de mykolaiv queremos
agradecer a dios a cervecería y matorral
librería por permitirnos grabar nuestro
programa en sus instalaciones a ustedes
también muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana sigue con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]